In New York, like in lots of cities, you can call 3-1-1 for help with city services, but also for all kinds of other stuff. The most common calls they get are about landlords not heating apartments properly. But they'll also help you get hold of a W-2 form you need from 2009. They'll tell you what streets will be blocked off for a presidential visit, connect you with the gas company, and a stunning array of other things-- 55,000 calls a day.
在纽约，像许多城市一样，你可以拨打 3-1-1 寻求市政服务方面的帮助，也可以咨询各种其他琐事。他们接到最常见的电话是关于房东没有给公寓提供足够暖气的投诉。但他们也会帮你获取 2009 年所需的 W-2 表格。他们会告诉你哪些街道会因为总统到访而封锁，帮你转接天然气公司，以及处理极其广泛的其他事项——每天有 55,000 通电话。
Actually, I had a call today.
实际上，我今天就接到了一个电话。
This is 311 operator Victoria Dusini.
这是 311 接线员维多利亚·杜西尼。
The woman said that her fiance died in their bed, and she was pregnant, and she wanted to identify his DNA in order to get social security benefits. So she wanted to know who to contact.
那位女士说她的未婚夫死在他们的床上，她当时怀孕了，她想确认他的 DNA 以获得社会保障福利。所以她想知道该联系谁。
She got a referral to family court, which can establish paternity, to the Social Security office to find out how to get the benefits, and a legal referral to the New York City Bar Association. Here's 311 operator Angelique Pantoja.
她得到了家事法院的转介信息，那里可以确定亲子关系；她还获得了社会保障办公室的联系方式以了解如何获得福利；以及纽约律师协会的法律转介。这是 311 接线员安吉丽克·潘托亚。
Well, a woman was cleaning her garage and she moved a box, and there was a crocodile. So I had to ask her, like a crocodile, like, big, with-- she's like, yeah, it's going snap, snap at me.
有一个女人在清理车库时挪动了一个箱子，里面有一只鳄鱼。所以我不得不问她，是鳄鱼吗？很大吗？她说，是的，它一直对着我张嘴咔哒咔哒响。
She says that was an easy one, of course-- call Animal Care and Control. But she also helped with this call.
她说这很简单，当然是打给动物护理与控制中心。但她也处理过这样的电话。
I had a woman who was-- I guess she had an unruly teenager. Even on the phone they were arguing. And she just couldn't take it. She couldn't take the disrespect, and she wanted help.
我接到过一个女人的电话，我想她有个叛逆的少年孩子。即便在电话里他们也在争吵。她实在受不了了。她无法忍受那种不尊重，她想寻求帮助。
That woman was given a referral for counseling services. The way all this works is that the operators sit at computers with a massive database of answers on thousands of different topics. They can help you locate where your car was towed. They can explain the changes in your property tax. They can help you find something you left in a New York City taxi, which, by the way, they can do even without the cab number now that taxis have GPS.
那位女士获得了心理咨询服务的转介。这一切运作的方式是，接线员坐在电脑前，面对着一个包含数千个不同主题答案的海量数据库。他们可以帮你定位你的车被拖到了哪里。他们可以解释你房产税的变化。他们可以帮你找回你落在纽约出租车上的东西——顺便提一下，现在出租车都有 GPS，即使没有车牌号也能找到。
But lots of people call for things that are not in the database. You see a UFO? 311 has no answers for you-- not in the database. You drop your keys in the sewer grate at the corner? New York City is not going to help you with that one, either.
但很多人打电话咨询的问题并不在数据库里。你看到了 UFO？311 没有答案给你——不在数据库里。你的钥匙掉进街角的下水道格栅里了？纽约市也不会帮你处理那个。
And people call with all kinds of stuff. I know a guy. He and his wife were in a taxicab riding home late at night from a Halloween party. He was dressed as a Teletubby. She was a sexy creature from the deep sea-- fishnet stockings, short skirt, fake seaweed. They got to their apartment. It's late at night. His wife told him, get out. She would continue in the cab. She wanted to spend the night elsewhere. So he got out of the cab. And not sure exactly what to do, he dialed 311. Operator picks up. He says, I don't know where my wife is. The operator asked, is she missing? He could be connected to the police. No, no, the guy says. And at that point, he realizes. Right, she's been staying out a lot. Right. She's having an affair.
人们打来电话询问各种各样的事情。我认识一个人。他和妻子在万圣节派对结束后深夜打车回家。他扮成天线宝宝。她扮成来自深海的性感生物——穿着渔网袜、短裙，带着假海藻。他们到了公寓。时间很晚了。妻子让他下车。她要继续乘车。她想去别的地方过夜。所以他下了车。不知道该怎么办，他拨打了 311。接线员接听了。他说，我不知道我妻子在哪。接线员问，她失踪了吗？他本可以被转接到警察局。不，不，那个人说。就在那一刻，他意识到了。对，她经常在外面过夜。对。她在搞外遇。
He didn't know exactly what it was that he wanted to get from 311. It's just he found himself suddenly not sure what had happened to him or how he got there. He had never been in this situation. It wasn't clear what to do.
他不知道自己到底想从 311 那里得到什么。他只是发现自己突然不知道发生了什么，也不知道自己怎么会走到这一步。他从未经历过这种情况。不清楚该怎么办。
We get those types of calls because we are known for a place that gives answers. So I guess, why not try 311?
我们会接到这类电话，因为我们以提供答案的地方而闻名。所以我想，为什么不试试 311 呢？
311 operator Natashia Townsend.
311 接线员娜塔莎·汤森。
I've had a caller-- she called to speak about her boyfriend. She felt like her boyfriend was going to leave her because he was a model and she just felt like he had a lot of attention from other women. So I would try to offer her different services, like, maybe some counseling for their relationship, and she didn't want it. She just wanted to speak to a 311 rep. She's like, no, I don't want to speak to anyone else. I just want to speak to 311. And there's nothing in our database that we use to say OK. Well, if he's doing this, this is what you should do.
我曾接到过一个来电者——她打电话来谈论她的男朋友。她觉得男朋友要离开她，因为他是个模特，她觉得他得到了太多其他女性的关注。所以我试着向她提供不同的服务，比如，也许可以进行一些关系咨询，但她不想要。她只是想和 311 的代表说话。她说，不，我不想和别人说话。我只想和 311 说话。我们的数据库里没有什么东西可以让我们说“好的，如果他这样做了，你应该这样做”。
Natashia found herself off the grid, so she improvised. She's not allowed to give personal advice, which she told the woman. So she basically said the only thing she could say in this situation that they did not train her for-- I understand. She said I understand over and over. The woman kept her on the phone for 45 minutes, and it seemed to help.
娜塔莎发现自己处于无据可查的境地，所以她即兴发挥。她不允许提供个人建议，她也告诉了那位女士。所以她基本说了她在这种未经培训的情况下唯一能说的话——我理解。她一遍又一遍地说我理解。那位女士在电话上让她听了 45 分钟，似乎有所帮助。
I think she felt better after she got off the phone.
我想她挂掉电话后感觉好多了。
How do you know?
你怎么知道？
She said thank you. She said thank you for listening to me. That's really what it was. She really just wanted to talk.
她说谢谢你。她说谢谢你倾听我。这真的就是全部。她真的只是想找人说话。
Well, from WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Today, on our program, what happens when you find yourself off the map, far from all the normal things you're used to and that you do, and things are way, way more extreme than they were for this 311 operator. You are lost in some situation you've never been in, and you've never heard of anybody else in, either, and you have to improvise, which either brings out a resource, heroic side of people, or just the opposite. Stay with us.
这里是 WBEZ 芝加哥，这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天，在我们的节目中，当你发现自己脱离了地图，远离了所有你习惯的、常做的事，情况比这位 311 接线员遇到的还要极端得多，会发生什么？你迷失在你从未经历过、也从未听说过别人经历过的情况中，你必须即兴发挥，这要么激发了人们足智多谋、英雄主义的一面，要么恰恰相反。留下来陪我们。
Act One-- Marriage of Inconvenience. This first story is about a couple who are in a relationship that is unlike the homes that either of them grew up in, unlike, actually, anything in either of their experiences. They're married, and it's a prison marriage. It's the guy who's the prisoner, and was a prisoner when they met.
第一幕——不便的婚姻。这第一个故事是关于一对夫妻，他们的关系与他们各自长大的家庭不同，实际上与他们任何经历中的事物都不同。他们结婚了，这是一场监狱婚姻。是那个男人是囚犯，而且他们相遇时他还是个囚犯。
If you're listening to our program on the podcast or on the internet, I just want to give you a heads-up. There's cursing in here that we have not beeped. If you prefer a beeped version of our program, you can hear that at our website, thisamericanlife.org.
如果你是通过播客或互联网收听我们的节目，我想提醒你一下。这里面有我们没有消音的咒骂。如果你更喜欢消音版的节目，可以在我们的网站 thisamericanlife.org 上收听。
Christopher Rhoads tells the story.
克里斯托弗·罗兹讲述这个故事。
Prison marriages aren't so unusual. They happen. Michael Jewell was serving out a life sentence for murder in Texas. Joan Covici was a widow living in Dallas who volunteered with the ACLU. They never thought that Michael would get out, and they were OK with that.
监狱婚姻并不罕见。它们确实存在。迈克尔·朱厄尔在德克萨斯州因谋杀罪服无期徒刑。琼·科维奇是一位住在达拉斯的寡妇，在美国公民自由联盟做志愿者。他们从未想过迈克尔会出狱，他们对此也没意见。
But sometimes they'd talk about what it would be like if he were released, to spend time together at her summer cabin in New Hampshire, go fishing together, be married for real. And five years into their relationship, when Michael decided to appeal his case, in the very unlikely event that he'd win, Joan wanted to be prepared, so she drew up a contract.
但有时他们会谈论如果他获释会是什么样子，一起在她在新罕布什尔州的夏季小屋度过时光，一起去钓鱼，真正地结婚。在他们交往五年后，当迈克尔决定上诉时，考虑到他获胜的可能性极小，琼想有所准备，所以她起草了一份合同。
We made kind of a pact-- and I still have that document-- that we would try it for two years. Whenever he got out, we would try it for two years. And if we weren't happy after two years, that we would separate.
我们达成了一个协议——那份文件我至今还保留着——我们会尝试两年。无论他什么时候出来，我们都会尝试两年。如果两年后我们不快乐，我们就分开。
Joan keeps the contract in her desk at home.
琼把这份合同放在家里的抽屉里。
"We, the undersigned, agree to the following arrangements, following--"
“我们，以下签署人，同意以下安排……”
The contract explicitly lays out all the very practical things that usually go unspoken in a relationship. Joan agrees that she'll provide Michael with a place to live and money for food and clothes. Michael agrees to take care of Joan, to be her companion. The contract is like a couple's fantasy of the most ordinary details of everyday life together. It gets amazingly specific. Here are some of Michael's duties.
合同明确规定了关系中通常不会明说的一切非常实际的事情。琼同意为迈克尔提供住所和食物及衣服的钱。迈克尔同意照顾琼，做她的伴侣。这份合同就像是一对夫妇对共同日常生活中最平凡细节的幻想。它非常具体。以下是迈克尔的一些职责。
"House chores-- 50% participation in cooking, cleaning, trash-takeout, bed-making, and minor household repairs. Outside chores-- yard and garden maintenance, dog-walking, shopping, driving, and car and air travel assistance. Here follow some specific obligations for Joan. House chores, 50% participation in cooking, cleaning, bed-making, and laundry, providing--"
“家务——参与 50% 的烹饪、清洁、倒垃圾、铺床和轻微的家庭维修。户外家务——庭院和花园维护、遛狗、购物、开车以及汽车和航空旅行协助。以下是琼的一些具体义务。家务，参与 50% 的烹饪、清洁、铺床和洗衣，提供……”
Without prison, it's unlikely that Michael and Joan would have ever met in the first place. She's 16 years older than he is, from a completely different world. Michael never knew much more than crime. When he was about seven, his father had him steal a pair of shoes. Things went downhill from there. Michael robbed grocery stores, cracked safes, he was in and out of prison. Then, in 1970, he killed a man during a robbery.
如果没有监狱，迈克尔和琼很可能永远不会相遇。她比他大 16 岁，来自一个完全不同的世界。迈克尔除了犯罪几乎什么都不知道。他大约七岁时，父亲让他去偷一双鞋。从那以后情况一落千丈。迈克尔抢劫杂货店，撬保险柜，进出监狱。然后，在 1970 年，他在一次抢劫中杀了一个人。
We spooked him, you know? We scared the hell out of him. And the wind was howling, and I was standing in front of him trying to tell him this is a robbery. Cooperate, and you won't get hurt. And he said, oh, oh, and made a motion like Matt Dillon going for the draw.
我们吓到他了，你知道吗？我们把他吓坏了。风在呼啸，我站在他面前试图告诉他这是一次抢劫。配合点，你就不会受伤。他说，哦，哦，然后做了一个像马特·狄龙准备拔枪的动作。
And my partner thought he was going for a pistol and shot him in the back. And when I heard the shot, just reflexively, I shot him in the chest. And when he hit ground, I knelt down and searched him, and he didn't even have a weapon. What he was trying to do was give us the bank sack.
我搭档以为他在找手枪，就向他的背部开了一枪。当我听到枪声时，出于反射，我也向他的胸部开了一枪。当他倒地时，我跪下搜他的身，他连武器都没有。他想做的是把银行袋子给我们。
Michael was caught and convicted, which, in Texas, means he wound up on death row. He was 23.
迈克尔被捕并被定罪，在德克萨斯州，这意味着他最终被判死刑。他当时 23 岁。
Joan's life in her early 20s was about as far from rural Texas as you can get in this country. She lived in Cambridge, Massachusetts, was married to a PhD student in English literature at Harvard named Pascal Covici, Jr. Pascal's father was the editor and lifelong friend of John Steinbeck, which meant that sometimes Joan got to go to intimate parties in New York City full of literary heavyweights.
琼 20 多岁时的生活离德克萨斯州的农村简直是天壤之别。她住在马萨诸塞州的剑桥，嫁给了一位名叫帕斯卡尔·科维奇二世的哈佛大学英语文学博士生。帕斯卡尔的父亲是约翰·斯坦贝克的编辑和终身朋友，这意味着琼有时可以去纽约参加充满文学大人物的私密派对。
Saul was often there-- Saul Bellow and Arthur.
索尔经常在那儿——索尔·贝娄和亚瑟。
Arthur Miller?
亚瑟·米勒？
Arthur Miller. When Arthur married Marilyn, of course, then everybody wanted to go to the dinner party.
亚瑟·米勒。当亚瑟娶了玛丽莲之后，每个人都想去那个晚宴。
Marilyn, of course, was Marilyn Monroe.
玛丽莲，当然，就是玛丽莲·梦露。
She was quiet. Didn't talk a whole lot, but she was so gorgeous. We all just sat there and looked at her and were happy that she was there. The men did most of the talking. And I was also quiet at those parties too. I didn't feel as comfortable. They were often talking about things that were not familiar to me-- about their work and politics. I had the baby by then, and that was taking up most of my attention.
她很安静。话不多，但她太漂亮了。我们都坐在那里看着她，很高兴她在那儿。男人们说了大部分的话。我在那些派对上也保持安静。我感觉不太自在。他们经常谈论我不熟悉的事情——关于他们的工作和政治。那时我已经有了孩子，这占据了我大部分的注意力。
Joan's marriage to Pascal was pretty standard for the time. He was the breadwinner. She was the homemaker. Joan raised two kids, eventually became a schoolteacher. And then, many years later, when Joan was 66, Pascal died of cancer.
琼与帕斯卡的婚姻在当时相当标准。他是养家糊口的人。她是家庭主妇。琼抚养了两个孩子，最终成为了一名学校教师。然后，多年以后，当琼 66 岁时，帕斯卡尔死于癌症。
After his death, she got more involved with volunteer work she'd been doing at the local ACLU chapter. She answered prison mail and started corresponding with several inmates to find out about conditions in the Texas prison system, which is how she'd first met Michael. He was 52, nearly 30 years into his prison sentence, and he sent a letter that found its way to Joan.
他去世后，她更多地参与了她在当地美国公民自由联盟分会做的志愿者工作。她回复监狱信件，并开始与几名囚犯通信，以了解德克萨斯州监狱系统的情况，这就是她最初遇到迈克尔的方式。他 52 岁，服刑已近 30 年，他寄出的一封信辗转到了琼手中。
It says, "Dear friends, I am a prisoner on the Eastham Unit of the Texas prison system. I came to prison with the death penalty in 1970. I stayed on death row--"
信中说：“亲爱的朋友们，我是德克萨斯州监狱系统伊斯特姆部门的一名囚犯。我于 1970 年因死刑入狱。我曾在死囚牢房……”
There was nothing special about Michael's letter. He was asking about getting involved with anti-death penalty work. His own death sentence had been commuted to life in 1973. And he'd become something of an activist in prison-- heavily involved in prison reform issues. Joan read his letter and dutifully wrote back. Then Michael wrote back, then Joan wrote, and so on. Michael and Joan wrote to each other almost every single day for 10 years.
迈克尔的信没什么特别的。他在询问如何参与反死刑工作。他自己的死刑在 1973 年被减为无期徒刑。他在监狱里成了某种活动家——深度参与监狱改革问题。琼读了他的信，认真地回了信。然后迈克尔回信，琼再回信，如此往复。迈克尔和琼在 10 年里几乎每天都给对方写信。
Michael was self-taught, but his letters showed how much he'd read, including most of John Steinbeck. And his intellect impressed Joan. She was constantly communicating with prisoners, 5 to 10 at a time, but Michael's letters stood out. He was a good writer. Take this letter he wrote to Joan after he intentionally injured himself-- cut his own Achilles tendon to protest work duty conditions.
迈克尔是自学的，但他的信件显示了他读过多少书，包括大部分约翰·斯坦贝克的作品。他的才智打动了琼。她经常同时与 5 到 10 名囚犯交流，但迈克尔的信脱颖而出。他是个好作家。看看这封他故意伤害自己后写给琼的信——为了抗议劳动条件，他切断了自己的跟腱。
"I had grown to love my body without narcissism, almost as a friend a faithful companion. It was, after all, my only refuge from the filth and the stench and the scorn. As I sit there contemplating the harsh task at hand, I felt like a traitor, as though I were committing the highest treason. It was most difficult to see a higher good in"--
“我已学会爱我的身体，没有自恋，几乎像一个忠实的朋友。毕竟，它是我逃避肮脏、恶臭和蔑视的唯一避难所。当我坐在那里思考手头的严酷任务时，我感到自己像个叛徒，好像我在犯下最高级别的叛国罪。很难看到更高的善……”
To me, he looked like James Cagney. He just was a perfect James Cagney, except that he didn't have very good teeth. He had just a few teeth on the bottom. So I saw him, and he was James Cagney, and I used to love James Cagney in his movies. But again, it wasn't love at first sight or anything like that because I'm not that sort of person. I go for the mind first. And he had a wonderful mind. And we just had lots to talk about.
对我来说，他看起来像詹姆斯·卡格尼。他简直就是一个完美的詹姆斯·卡格尼，除了他的牙齿不太好。他的下排只有几颗牙齿。所以我看到了他，他就是詹姆斯·卡格尼，我过去在电影里很喜欢詹姆斯·卡格尼。但再次说明，这不是一见钟情之类的，因为我不是那种人。我先看重思想。他有一个美妙的思想。我们有很多话要聊。
It wasn't all intellectual. In his letters, Michael started using pet names for Joan. He'd call her Sweet Baby Joan and other things, too.
这不全是智力上的交流。在信中，迈克尔开始给琼起昵称。他叫她甜心琼和其他一些称呼。
"Dear noble little squaw, sweet baby." "Dearest finger-licking-good sweet baby." "Dear honey butt." [LAUGHS]
“亲爱的尊贵的印第安小姑娘，甜心。”“最亲爱的让人想舔手指的甜心。”“亲爱的蜂蜜屁股。”（笑）
In her letters, Joan loosened up, as well.
在她的信中，琼也放松了下来。
"I think I'll fix a big scotch and go sit in the back yard and smoke a cigarette and try to get you into perspective. God, I wish you were here to spank." (LAUGHING) Can I stop there?
“我想我会倒一大杯苏格兰威士忌，坐在后院抽支烟，试着把你带入视角。天哪，我希望你在这里，这样我就能打你屁股。”（笑）我能停在那儿吗？
Every Sunday afternoon, Joan would drive the few hours to visit Michael in prison-- a book on tape playing on the car stereo. She'd stay at the same fancy bed and breakfast near the prison, became friends with the people who ran the place, and then the rest of the week, she got to go back to her own life and did what she wanted to do. It was romance, but on her terms-- something she'd never experienced.
每个星期天下午，琼都会开车几小时去监狱探视迈克尔——车里播放着有声书。她会住在监狱附近同一家高档民宿，和经营那儿的人成了朋友，然后一周剩下的时间，她回到自己的生活做她想做的事。这是一段罗曼史，但以她的方式——她从未经历过。
Michael and Joan would hug and kiss discreetly on their contact visits. This was all in a public visiting room. There was nothing conjugal about what was going on. The limits of their time together were clear, and Joan was happy with the arrangement.
迈克尔和琼在接触探视时会谨慎地拥抱和亲吻。这一切都在公共探视室里。他们所做的没有任何夫妻间的意思。他们在一起的时间限制很明确，琼对这种安排很满意。
I kind of liked being alone. It's very comfortable for a woman to know that somebody loves her, and yet, she has all this freedom to live her own life.
我有点喜欢独处。对于一个女人来说，知道有人爱她，同时又能拥有完全自由的生活，是非常舒服的。
Michael and Joan knew that, no matter how close they became, they'd never really be together. Rarely, if ever, does a former death row inmate get paroled in Texas. So really, what they had was their letters. Here's another one from Joan.
迈克尔和琼都知道，无论他们变得多么亲密，他们永远不会真正地在一起。在德克萨斯州，前死囚几乎不可能获得假释。所以，他们真正拥有的是他们的信件。这是琼的另一封信。
"A song that has always torn my heart is the 'September Song.' You remember-- 'And these few precious days I'll spend with you.' "
“一首总是让我心碎的歌是《九月之歌》。你记得吗——‘这几个珍贵的日子我将与你共度。’”
[MUSIC - WILLIE NELSON, "SEPTEMBER SONG"]
[音乐 - 威利·尼尔森，《九月之歌》]
"And especially in our case, the days are few, and we may never spend them really together. We must get used to this reality and not ruin what years remain. I love you, precious Michael-- SBJ"-- Sweet Baby Joan.
“特别是在我们的情况下，日子不多了，我们可能永远无法真正地在一起。我们必须习惯这个现实，不要毁掉余下的岁月。我爱你，珍贵的迈克尔——SBJ”——甜心琼。
[MUSIC - WILLIE NELSON, "SEPTEMBER SONG"]
[音乐 - 威利·尼尔森，《九月之歌》]
In 2005, they got married, but that was mainly so that they wouldn't lose their visitation rights. The prison had denied them visits before. And they lived this way, happily, for five years. Then, in June 2010, Michael was summoned by prison authorities. He walked into a room, and an official came to speak to him.
2005 年，他们结婚了，但这主要是为了不失去探视权。监狱之前拒绝过他们的探视。他们就这样快乐地生活了五年。然后，在 2010 年 6 月，迈克尔被监狱当局传唤。他走进一个房间，一名官员来和他谈话。
He said, are you Jewell? I said, yeah. He said, here, I got a present for you. And he handed me a sheet of paper. And I started reading it, and I had made parole.
他说，你是朱厄尔吗？我说，是的。他说，给你，我有份礼物给你。他递给我一张纸。我开始读它，我获得了假释。
Michael was confused. Just a month or so before, he'd gone before the parole board and been denied, just as he had been many times before.
迈克尔很困惑。就在一个月前，他还在假释委员会面前，被拒绝了，就像他之前多次被拒绝一样。
I think I stopped breathing for about two or three minutes. I didn't really-- I was kind of-- my first reaction was, this has got to be a fucking mistake, you know? It was unheard of, you know? Something like that happens once every 10 years in prison to somebody.
我想我大概有两三分钟没呼吸。我真的——我有点——我的第一反应是，这一定是该死的错误，你知道吗？这简直闻所未闻。在监狱里，这种事每 10 年才会发生一次。
Michael has no real idea why he was paroled. He thinks it might have had something to do with a lawsuit he filed against the prison system, saying that it was understaffed and unsafe. Releasing Michael made the lawsuit go away.
迈克尔根本不知道他为什么会获得假释。他认为这可能与他针对监狱系统提起的一项诉讼有关，称其人手不足且不安全。释放迈克尔让诉讼消失了。
I think it was a surprise to both of us when he suddenly was put on the street. He was scared at the thought of coming out. He wasn't prepared for it. Neither one of us was, really.
我想当他突然被放到街上时，对我们俩来说都是个惊喜。他想到要出来感到害怕。他没有准备好。我们俩其实都没准备好。
I wanted him home, and I knew it was going to be hard. I knew it was going to be difficult. And I knew that the chances of the relationship lasting were very bad. But I had agreed to try it, and so--
我想要他回家，我知道这会很难。我知道这会很困难。我知道关系持续下去的可能性非常小。但我已经同意尝试，所以……
Do you think that you would have gotten into the relationship as you did and to the degree that you did if you knew that he was actually going to get out one day?
你认为如果你知道他真的有一天会出来，你还会像那样、并在那种程度上进入这段关系吗？
I can't answer that. I really don't know.
我无法回答。我真的不知道。
Now, with Michael about to be released-- the contract we'd talked about at the beginning of this story, the one that laid out all the shared household and relationship duties should Michael, a convicted murderer, ever get paroled-- that contract was about to be put into effect.
现在，随着迈克尔即将获释——我们在这个故事开头谈到的合同，那份规定了如果迈克尔这个被定罪的杀人犯获得假释，双方共同承担家务和关系职责的合同——那份合同即将生效。
The contract stipulated a two-year trial period for their marriage. If it turned into a real marriage, fine. If it didn't, they would go their separate ways. Joan could fire Michael, or he could quit-- those are their words-- at any time. Nobody keeps statistics on how long prison marriages last on the outside, but lots of prison people will tell you most end before a year is up.
合同规定了为期两年的婚姻试用期。如果它变成真正的婚姻，那就很好。如果不成，他们就会各奔东西。琼可以解雇迈克尔，或者他可以辞职——这是他们的用词——在任何时候。没有人统计监狱婚姻在外面能持续多久，但很多监狱里的人会告诉你，大多数在一年内就结束了。
On August 21, 2010, after 40 years in prison, and 10 years with Joan, Michael was a free man. Joan was waiting for him in a parked car at the prison gates, wearing an earring Michael had made for her. Joan was so nervous and excited that she hadn't slept the night before. She had a whole romantic vision for the day. She'd made a reservation at a five-star hotel. Michael walked out wearing his prison-issued jumpsuit, nervous, and overwhelmed to be out.
2010 年 8 月 21 日，在监狱服刑 40 年并与琼交往 10 年后，迈克尔成了一个自由人。琼在监狱大门口的一辆停着的车里等他，戴着迈克尔为她制作的耳环。琼非常紧张和兴奋，以至于前一天晚上没睡着。她对这一天有一个浪漫的设想。她在一家五星级酒店订了房。迈克尔穿着监狱发的连体服走出来，紧张，对获释感到不知所措。
And he didn't kiss me or anything. He just got into the car and said, let's go. So it was a very unromantic meeting, and it kind of hurt me.
他没有吻我或做别的什么。他只是上了车说，走吧。所以这是一次非常不浪漫的会面，这多少伤了我的心。
I was elated, but I was kind of bewildered. I don't think you can describe it.
我欣喜若狂，但我有点困惑。我想你无法形容它。
I thought he would be as warm to see me as he was in the visiting rooms, where he would hug me and try to steal an extra kiss or something. Oh, no. He was very businesslike. It wasn't what they show in the movies at all.
我以为他见到我会像在探视室里一样热情，在那儿他会拥抱我，试图偷个吻之类的。哦，不。他非常公事公办。这根本不是电影里演的那样。
As comprehensive as the contract was, it didn't cover everything. It didn't occur to them to include anything about sex. A quick warning to anyone listening with kids, this next bit of the story is about that.
尽管合同很全面，但它没有涵盖所有事情。他们没想过要写进关于性爱的内容。给带孩子的听众一个简短的警告，故事的下一部分是关于那个的。
Michael had never had sex with someone he loved. And 40 years in prison left him pretty messed up on that subject.
迈克尔从未与他爱的人发生过性关系。在监狱里待了 40 年让他在这方面感到非常糟糕。
I did not expect him to be so afraid to cuddle. If we have our clothes on, he hugs me all day long. But getting naked with somebody makes him very uncomfortable.
我没料到他这么害怕拥抱。如果我们穿着衣服，他整天都在拥抱我。但和某人赤身裸体让他非常不舒服。
Especially the last few years, she had taken on more and more of a mother figure to me. And when we got in a hotel room together, then I started pacing the floor, identifying with Oedipus Rex, if you know what I mean.
特别是最后几年，她越来越像一个母亲形象对我。当我们一起走进酒店房间时，我开始在地上踱步，认同俄狄浦斯王，如果你明白我的意思的话。
I think what he means is their relationship had shifted over the years. And she was now 79, remember-- 16 years older than Michael. Once they were in a hotel room, they realized that the nature of their feelings toward each other were really complicated.
我想他的意思是他们的关系这些年来发生了转变。记住，她当时 79 岁——比迈克尔大 16 岁。一旦他们在一起，他们意识到彼此的感觉实际上非常复杂。
Over the years they'd known each other, Joan had gone from initially feeling like she wanted to adopt Michael, to wanting to sleep with him to, now that he was out, a kind of mishmash of all those feelings.
在他们认识的这些年里，琼从最初觉得想收养迈克尔，到想和他发生关系，再到他出来后，所有这些感觉的混合体。
He's still an adopted child, and he's still my best companion, and I love him, and he's my best friend. So it's all together. And I'm comfortable with it.
他仍然是一个被收养的孩子，他仍然是我最好的伴侣，我爱他，他是我最好的朋友。所以一切都在一起。我对此感到舒服。
So Michael moved into Joan's suburban ranch house in Dallas and got to know her family and friends. There were lots of academics, all sorts of people and settings he'd never encountered before. She was surprised how well he did socially, but they had their rocky moments.
所以迈克尔搬进了琼在达拉斯的郊区牧场式住宅，并认识了她的家人和朋友。那里有很多学者，各种各样他从未接触过的人和环境。她对他在社交方面的表现感到惊讶，但他们也有艰难的时刻。
Joan took Michael to a wine-tasting party and he got fall-down drunk. Joan had to haul him outside to avoid making a scene. This happened two or three times. He never really drank socially before, usually, just to get hammered. And at parties with Joan, he'd go too far, partly to calm his nerves. One of Joan's friends-- someone who'd been close to Joan's first husband, Pascal-- was appalled by her choice of a second husband and ended their friendship.
琼带迈克尔参加一个品酒会，他喝得烂醉。琼不得不把他拉到外面以免闹出乱子。这种情况发生了两三次。他以前从未真正进行过社交饮酒，通常只是为了买醉。在和琼参加派对时，他做得太过火了，部分是为了平复神经。琼的一位朋友——和琼的第一任丈夫帕斯卡尔很亲近的人——对她选择的第二任丈夫感到震惊，并结束了他们的友谊。
It's now been four years since Michael got out. They've made it way past the trial period in their contract. Michael still leaves the stove on and the front door open-- things he never had to think about when he was in prison. He leaves his stuff lying around everywhere. Joan says it's like having a teenager in the house again. But they've learned to deal with all this. Their lives are intertwined now.
迈克尔出来已经四年了。他们已经远远超过了合同中的试用期。迈克尔仍然会开着炉子，开着前门——他在监狱里从不需要考虑这些事情。他把东西扔得随处可见。琼说这就像家里又有个十几岁的孩子。但他们学会了处理这一切。他们的生活现在交织在一起了。
Somehow, there's an equality of people in this marriage that I didn't have before. I was too dependent upon my husband and his reputation. But with Michael, it's just-- you know, I figure I've become free in some strange way. The neighbors have to accept us the way we are now. They got a criminal in their neighborhood. I love to have him out there with all of his tats all over him.
不知何故，这段婚姻里有一种以前我没有过的人格平等。我太依赖我的丈夫和他的名声了。但和迈克尔在一起，就——你知道，我觉得我以一种奇怪的方式获得了自由。邻居们现在必须接受我们的现状。他们的社区里有个罪犯。我喜欢他带着满身纹身出现在外面。
Now that Joan is in her early 80s, she's started to wonder what's going to happen to Michael when she's gone. That wasn't in the contract. Joan figures maybe they've got another seven years together.
既然琼已经 80 出头了，她开始担心当她去世后迈克尔会发生什么。合同里没写这个。琼觉得也许他们还有七年的共同时光。
We'll have to find you another old lady to take you in.
我们得再给你找个老太太收留你。
(LAUGHING) Prospects are going to be few and far between.
（笑）前景会很少，也很遥远。
(LAUGHING) I'll find another kindergarten teacher who will really shape you up.
（笑）我会再找个幼儿园老师来好好改造你。
Well, we often say that we should die together. So maybe we'll drive into a freight train or get hit by an 18-wheeler.
嗯，我们常说我们应该一起死。所以也许我们会开车冲向货运列车，或者被 18 轮大卡车撞到。
Well, what about a plane crash? Don't you like that idea?
嗯，空难怎么样？你不喜欢那个主意吗？
No.
不。
Oh, no, not that?
哦，不，不喜欢那个？
No, I'd rather drown.
不，我宁愿淹死。
Oh. (LAUGHING) I see.
哦。（笑）我明白了。
Until that day, whether they go out together or not, they like to watch Downton Abbey together. They go to plays. Recently, they went to see a Tennessee Williams play at a community theater near their house. And these two people, who have lived very different lives, had the same reaction. They thought the play sucked. They left at intermission.
在那一天到来之前，无论他们是否一起走，他们都喜欢一起看《唐顿庄园》。他们去看戏。最近，他们去看了住处附近的一家社区剧院演出的田纳西·威廉姆斯的剧。而这两个经历过截然不同生活的人，反应却一样。他们觉得这剧糟透了。幕间休息时他们就离开了。
Christopher Rhoads.
克里斯托弗·罗兹。
It's been four years since we first broadcast that story, and today's program. Joan and Michael are still together. They're dealing with some difficult things right now. She's going through chemo. He moved into a treatment center for alcoholism, though, he's back in the house two or three times a week and stays over on weekends.
自我们首次播出那个故事已经四年了，今天的节目。琼和迈克尔仍然在一起。他们现在正在处理一些困难的事情。她正在接受化疗。他搬进了一个酗酒治疗中心，虽然他每周还是会回家两三次，周末留宿。
Coming up, Brother, Can You Spare a Lime? Siblings on a road trip through Mexico that is unlike anything either one of them imagined beforehand. Also, comedian Tig Notaro. That's in a minute from Chicago Public Radio when our program continues.
接下来，兄弟，能给点酸橙吗？兄弟姐妹在墨西哥的公路旅行，与他们中任何一个人事先想象的都不同。还有，喜剧演员蒂格·诺塔罗。在一分钟后芝加哥公共广播电台继续我们的节目。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our program, of course, we choose a theme and bring you different kinds of stories on that theme. Today's program-- Wait-- Do You Have the Map-- stories of people in situations they have no preparation for whatsoever because most people have not been in those situations. In the second half of our program, both stories take place where you need a map-- that is, on the road.
这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。每周在我们的节目中，当然，我们会选择一个主题，并为您带来关于该主题的各种故事。今天的节目——等等——你有地图吗——关于人们处于毫无准备的情况下的故事，因为大多数人没有经历过那些情况。在节目的下半部分，两个故事都发生在你需要地图的地方——也就是在路上。
We've arrived at Act Two of our program. Act Two-- Final Rest Stop. Tig Notaro is a comedian who's been on our program before. Back in 2013, she went on a tour across the country that was filmed. It was a strange tour. She and this Canadian comic named Jon Dore went around the country performing in people's living rooms and their backyards and just lots of situations where they had to ad hoc their way through what they were doing. One of our producers, Nancy Updike, saw the film, which has many, many moments in it that fit today's theme. Here's Nancy.
我们到达了我们节目的第二幕。第二幕——最后一个休息站。蒂格·诺塔罗是一位曾上过我们节目的喜剧演员。回到 2013 年，她进行了全国巡演，并被拍摄了下来。那是一场奇怪的巡演。她和一位名叫乔恩·多尔的加拿大喜剧演员在全国各地表演，在人们的客厅和后院，以及许多他们不得不即兴发挥的情况中进行表演。我们的制片人南希·厄普代克看了这部电影，里面有很多很多符合今天主题的时刻。这是南希。
Tig and John are like door-to-door comedy salesmen in the film-- invited salesmen-- showing up at people's houses and knocking on their doors. But my favorite parts of the movie are just Tig and Jon in the car in between gigs-- the road trip part of the movie. Jon's always driving, sometimes using special Canadian mind exercises to either stay alert or to annoy Tig.
蒂格和乔恩在电影里就像上门的喜剧推销员——受邀的推销员——出现在人们家门口敲门。但我最喜欢的部分是蒂格和乔恩在演出间隙在车里的情景——电影的公路旅行部分。乔恩总是在开车，有时使用特殊的加拿大心理练习来保持清醒或者惹恼蒂格。
I'm going to name as many--
我要列举尽可能多的——
No. No, no, no.
不。不，不，不。
--Montreal Expos--
——蒙特利尔博览会队——
No, no, no.
不，不，不。
--as I can.
——我能说的。
No, no, no.
不，不，不。
Andrés Galarraga, Tim Wallach, Tim Raines--
安德烈斯·加拉拉加，蒂姆·沃拉克，蒂姆·雷恩斯——
They talk in the car, riff on each other's jokes. It's like watching dancers staying limber between performances. Tig shows off her incredible impression of a clown's horn.
他们在车里聊天，互相即兴发挥对方的笑话。就像看着舞者在表演间隙保持灵活性。蒂格展示了她令人难以置信的小丑喇叭模仿。
[HONKING]
[喇叭声]
That's really good.
真不错。
[HONKING]
[喇叭声]
They both look like they're having a really good time. Then, as Jon is wrapping up his impression of Johnny Carson auditioning for Jodie Foster's role in Silence of the Lambs, Tig suddenly grimaces in pain.
他们看起来都玩得很开心。然后，当乔恩正在结束他模仿强尼·卡森为朱迪·福斯特在《沉默的羔羊》中的角色试镜时，蒂格突然因疼痛而皱起眉头。
Ow.
哎。
What happened?
怎么了？
I just get stomach pains.
我只是胃痛。
Is this something I need to be worried about, or is this just, like, your stomachache?
这是我需要担心的吗，还是只是像你胃痛那样？
No, nothing to be worried about.
不，没什么可担心的。
Do you need to take a moment?
你需要休息一下吗？
If it continued for a while, then there would be trouble.
如果持续一段时间，那就会有麻烦。
Do you need to take a moment?
你需要休息一下吗？
Nope. I just have pains every now and then.
不需要。我只是时不时地有疼痛。
Tig had cancer two years ago-- famously, if you follow comedy. It was breast cancer, advanced. She had a double mastectomy. A few months before the cancer was diagnosed, Tig was in the hospital with a terrible, sometimes deadly, infection called C. diff.
蒂格两年前得了癌症——如果你关注喜剧的话，这很有名。那是乳腺癌，晚期。她做了双乳切除术。在癌症诊断出几个月前，蒂格因为一种可怕的、有时致命的感染“艰难梭菌”而在医院。
Over the course of the tour, driving around, doing gigs, Tig and Jon log enough hours together that they get into all of that-- illness, fear of death. They joke about it. They're serious about it. They navigate it.
在巡演的过程中，开车到处走，表演节目，蒂格和乔恩在一起的时间足够长，以至于他们谈论了所有这些——疾病，对死亡的恐惧。他们开玩笑说。他们认真地谈论它。他们驾驭它。
And at some point in the trip, Jon and Tig pull over at a roadside store that sells fireworks and tombstones. Maybe two different people on a different road trip wouldn't have stopped or wouldn't have stayed if they stopped. But as friends who were also comics, they both head into the field of tombstones and start improvising, neither of them knowing where this is going to lead and whether it's going to be funny or maybe a terrible idea.
在旅途中的某个时刻，乔恩和蒂格在一家销售烟花和墓碑的路边商店停车。也许两个在不同公路旅行上的人不会停下来，或者如果停下来也不会停留。但作为同样是喜剧演员的朋友，他们都走进墓碑地，开始即兴表演，两人都不知道这会导向哪里，也不知道这是会很有趣，还是一个糟糕的主意。
Hey, let's get you a headstone.
嘿，给你弄个墓碑吧。
Yeah. Let's get me a headstone.
好的。给我弄个墓碑。
Tig explains to the owner of the store why she and Jon are looking for a headstone for her.
蒂格向店主解释为什么她和乔恩在为她寻找墓碑。
I've had some health issues lately.
我最近有一些健康问题。
Oh.
哦。
This one's nice and cute.
这个挺可爱，不错的。
I just want to be smart, think ahead. All right.
我只是想变得聪明，未雨绸缪。好吧。
Wow.
哇。
So this one's $250?
所以这个是 250 美元吗？
Yeah.
是的。
I really like this one.
我真的很喜欢这个。
Tig, at this point, is touching a modest, flat slab on the ground.
蒂格此时正在触摸地上的一块朴素平坦的石板。
See, now that's just the bottom. You could have that engraved, right, and just use that?
你看，那只是底座。你可以在上面雕刻，对吧，然后直接用那个？
Yeah.
是的。
That's the owner.
那是店主。
But you would want--
但你会想要——
That.
那个。
I would buy you this. I would love to buy your headstone.
我会给你买这个。我很乐意买你的墓碑。
Jon's pointing to an upright headstone. Tig seems momentarily thrown, like, are we still playing here?
乔恩指向一个竖立的墓碑。蒂格似乎暂时被弄糊涂了，像是，我们在玩吗？
All right.
好吧。
I'm not joking. I'd love to do this for you.
我不是在开玩笑。我很乐意为你做这个。
OK.
好的。
I'd buy your headstone if you buy the base.
如果你买底座，我就买你的墓碑。
All right. Because I'm more than happy to just have that.
好的。因为我很高兴只拥有那个。
You should have this, don't you think?
你应该有这个，你不觉得吗？
OK.
好的。
What is that without this?
没有这个那个算什么？
That is a base.
那是个底座。
Yeah, but what are you going to do with a base?
是的，但你有底座能做什么？
I'm going to go under it.
我要去它下面。
You should have this.
你应该有这个。
Let me stop the tape. That pause-- that's Jon's moment to be stunned by the directness of, "I'm going to go under it." Then he recovers and keeps going.
让我关掉录音。那个停顿——那是乔恩被“我要去它下面”的直接性惊呆的时刻。然后他恢复过来并继续说。
You should have this. People are not going to want to stand over it and read. They're going to want to look at it from a distance. Look at-- if you get something like this, people can sit down in front of it and cry. So you're underneath me, right? And I'm just bawling my eyes out, and I can read it here. I don't have to kneel down and come all the way over there.
你应该有这个。人们不会想站着读。他们会想从远处看。你看——如果你有这样的东西，人们可以坐在它前面哭泣。所以你就在我下面，对吧？我只是泪流满面，我可以在这里读。我不必跪下来走到那儿。
Yeah.
是的。
I can bring a lawn chair.
我可以带把草坪椅。
I guess this is hard on the back.
我想这对背部很辛苦。
Yeah.
是的。
To do this.
做这个。
I'd be in a lawn chair. I'd be there for hours.
我会坐在草坪椅上。我会在那里待上几个小时。
You'd spend some time.
你会花点时间。
You'd look beautiful under that.
你在那下面看起来会很美。
I like it. I like it.
我喜欢它。我喜欢它。
Jon buys the headstone. It's $425-- cheap for a tombstone, expensive for a joke. Then they get back on the road.
乔恩买了墓碑。它要 425 美元——对于墓碑来说很便宜，对于笑话来说很贵。然后他们又上路了。
I watched this scene a bunch of times, the way they pushed the joke forward but kept saying real things with real feelings. It was a game, and the game was keep it going. Don't stop. Let's see where this goes.
我看了很多遍这个场景，他们如何推进这个笑话，但又一直在用真实的感情说真实的话。这是一个游戏，游戏规则是继续下去。不要停止。让我们看看这会导向哪里。
Nancy Updike, playing an excerpt from the film, Knock Knock, It's Tig Notaro. If you're in Los Angeles on March 31, you can catch Tig at Largo. All of her upcoming show dates are at tignotaro.com.
南希·厄普代克，播放电影《敲敲门，是蒂格·诺塔罗》的节选。如果你在 3 月 31 日在洛杉矶，可以在 Largo 看蒂格的演出。她所有的即将举行的演出日期都在 tignotaro.com。
[MUSIC - MARVIN PONTIAC, "SMALL CAR"]
[音乐 - 马文·庞蒂亚克，《小汽车》]
Act Three-- Not All Who Wander Are Lost, But Some Definitely Are. A car is a classic place to realize, oh right, I'm lost. Though sometimes, you realize that you're lost. You're, like, personally lost, and then you get into the car and you drive as far as you can to solve that problem. James Spring has this story. It's partly about that.
第三幕——不是所有徘徊的人都迷失了，但有些人确实迷失了。汽车是一个意识到“哦，对了，我迷路了”的经典地点。虽然有时，你意识到你迷路了。你是，比如，个人迷失了，然后你钻进车里，尽可能远地开车去解决那个问题。詹姆斯·斯普林有这个故事。它部分是关于那个的。
There's this guy that I've known forever. His name's Kevin. He's about 40, a father now with two kids. But back in the summer of 1989, when Kevin had just turned 16, his dad let him drive from San Diego to Central America with his older brother. Kevin was super excited. It was the adventure of a lifetime. He'd saved up nearly $1,000 working after school at a yogurt shop.
有个家伙我认识很久了。他叫凯文。他大约 40 岁，现在有两个孩子。但在 1989 年夏天，当凯文刚满 16 岁时，他爸爸让他带着他哥哥开车从圣地亚哥去中美洲。凯文超级兴奋。那是一生难得的冒险。他在放学后在酸奶店工作存了近 1,000 美元。
Kevin's brother, who was 21 at the time, knew parts of Mexico pretty well. After he'd dropped out of college, it seemed that he was down in Baja all the time. He was a hard charger, lived with a bunch of tattooed guys who looked like felons. He drove this kick-ass red Jeep with no doors. So a little wild, but he'd always looked out for Kevin since they were little kids. Kevin wasn't worried.
凯文的哥哥，当时 21 岁，对墨西哥部分地区很了解。在他大学辍学后，他似乎总是在下加利福尼亚州。他是个冲动的人，和一群看起来像重罪犯的纹身家伙住在一起。他开着这辆没有任何门的酷炫红色吉普车。所以有点野，但他从小就一直照顾凯文。凯文并不担心。
Good guy to travel with. He'll watch out for me. We'll learn some Spanish, drink beer, and smoke cigarettes.
很适合旅行的家伙。他会照顾我的。我们会学点西班牙语，喝啤酒，抽香烟。
But there were other interesting facts about Kevin's brother, too, some of which would soon become concerns. That thing that the brother was doing in Baja-- not legal. The tattooed guys who looked like felons were, in fact, felons. And actually, Kevin's brother, himself, had recently been released from a short stint in county jail. The older brother had anger issues. He was a control freak.
但关于凯文的哥哥还有其他有趣的事实，其中一些很快会成为顾虑。他哥哥在下加利福尼亚州做的那件事——不合法。那些看起来像重罪犯的纹身家伙，事实上就是重罪犯。事实上，凯文的哥哥本人最近刚从县监狱刑满释放。那个哥哥有愤怒问题。他是个控制狂。
So the trip-- I mean, it sucked. It ended badly, and it ended early. There was a blowout fight. Two drove down. One flew back.
所以这次旅行——我的意思是，糟透了。它以糟糕的方式结束，而且很早就结束了。发生了一场激烈的争吵。两人开车下去。一人坐飞机回来。
I was happy to get on a plane and go home. I'd had enough of the driving. I'd had enough of my asshole brother. And now it had become a fight. And even though we had fought before, really, this was the worst one.
我很高兴能坐上飞机回家。我受够了开车。我受够了我那混蛋哥哥。现在它变成了一场争吵。尽管我们以前吵过，但真的，这是最严重的一次。
There's one more important thing to know about Kevin and his brother. When they were kids, they'd been everything to each other-- super close, like war buddies-- because they grew up with a stepfather who was a real bastard-- violent. And they moved around a lot. Every year, a new school. No friends-- really, just each other.
关于凯文和他哥哥还有一件事很重要。当他们小时候，他们是彼此的一切——超级亲密，就像战争伙伴——因为他们成长在一个继父是真正人渣的环境中——暴力。他们搬家很频繁。每年一所新学校。没有朋友——真的，只有彼此。
This trip, that fight-- it decimated their relationship. The two never really spoke about the trip again, didn't speak much at all. It's been more than 20 years. I wanted to talk to Kevin about this and how he feels about it now, since I already know how his brother feels about this. Because I'm his brother.
这次旅行，那场争吵——彻底摧毁了他们的关系。两人再也没有真正谈论过这次旅行，几乎没怎么说话。已经超过 20 年了。我想和凯文谈谈这个，以及他现在对此的感受，因为我已经知道他哥哥对此的感受了。因为我是他哥哥。
OK. We're recording. You good?
好了。我们在录音了。你还好吗？
All right. I'm good.
好的。我很好。
[DING]
[叮]
Was that me?
那是我的声音吗？
I think so.
我想是吧。
Talk about the long trip?
聊聊那次漫长的旅行？
When I first suggested that we talk, Kevin was ambivalent. I think he wondered why-- like, what good could come of it-- which is fair because I have not been an easy guy to talk to. But I had some things I wanted to say. And look, in this story, I'm not going to come off well. I was a real prick.
当我第一次建议我们聊聊时，凯文很矛盾。我想他想知道为什么——比如，能有什么好处——这很公平，因为我一直不是个容易交流的人。但我有些话想说。看，在这个故事里，我表现得不太好。我当时真是个混蛋。
In the late '80s, I was the first person in my family to get into college. I dropped out after six months. Some friends let me crash with them. One night, I threw a party that went off the rails and three shots rang out from a semiautomatic handgun. The idiot that fired the gun? That was me-- my gun-- evicted.
在 80 年代后期，我是家里第一个上大学的人。我在六个月后辍学了。一些朋友让我和他们住在一起。一天晚上，我举办的派对失控了，半自动手枪响了三声。开枪的白痴？那就是我——我的枪——被驱逐了。
Then I started hanging with some truly bad people. We were running ephedrine and coke from Baja into San Diego. One night, there was a drug raid at our house. Everything got flushed down the toilets before the cops got through the door, but I still got arrested. Through all of this, though, I still somehow had this great girlfriend, just really sweet and wonderful. Then I slept with some other girl. You know what that got me? Gonorrhea is what it got me, and no girlfriend. I ruined so much, so much. But I could run away from almost all of it and take penicillin for the rest.
然后我开始和一些真正糟糕的人混在一起。我们在从下加利福尼亚州往圣地亚哥运送麻黄碱和可卡因。一天晚上，我们家遭到了一次毒品突击搜查。在警察进门前一切都被冲进马桶了，但我还是被捕了。尽管如此，我不知何故还是有一个很棒的女朋友，非常甜美可爱。然后我和别的女孩睡了。你知道那让我得到了什么吗？得到了淋病，而且没了女朋友。我毁掉了很多，很多。但我几乎可以逃避这一切，并服用青霉素来度过余生。
I was 21 years old, a colossal mess, and I just wanted to get in my Jeep and drive to Mexico and beyond-- see the temples of the Aztecs, the Mayan ruins. So I prepared to drive all the way to Central America for the summer. And I would take with me the one person who I was sure didn't think I was such a bad guy.
我 21 岁，是个巨大的烂摊子，我只想钻进我的吉普车开车去墨西哥及更远的地方——看看阿兹特克的神庙，玛雅遗址。所以我准备开车去中美洲过暑假。我会带上我唯一确定不认为我是个坏家伙的人。
And I was done being that bad guy, anyway-- that shallow, selfish me that people hated. I was ready to throw myself into something real on this trip, something important, something smart. Before we left, I removed the backseat from the Jeep and replaced it with a welded lockbox with maybe two suitcases worth of storage space. Then I loaded it with a lot of books. I'd always been a reader, like a studier, and my plan for the summer was, sure, hang out with my brother, but also to learn the language of the Lacandon Mayans. And I was going to learn to read the Mesoamerican hieroglyphs. I even made flashcards for myself.
反正我也不想当那个坏家伙了——那个人们讨厌的肤浅、自私的我。我准备在这趟旅行中投入一些真实的东西，一些重要、聪明的东西。我们出发前，我把吉普车的后座拆了，换成了一个焊接的锁箱，大约有两个手提箱的存储空间。然后我装了许多书。我一直是个读者，像个书呆子，我那个暑假的计划是，当然，和哥哥待在一起，但也要学习拉坎顿玛雅人的语言。我还要学习阅读美索不达米亚象形文字。我甚至给自己做了识字卡。
This trip would be an opportunity for me to figure out once and for all why the Mayan civilization disappeared. Yeah. Archaeologists had been on the job for more than a century, and still nobody knew why all these cities were abandoned. But I was pretty sure that this summer, I was going to get it nailed down. All answers lay somewhere in those lost cities deep in the jungle. And lucky Kevin, he was about to see every one of them.
这次旅行对我来说是一个弄清楚玛雅文明为何消失的机会。是的。考古学家已经工作了一个多世纪，仍然没人知道为什么所有这些城市都被废弃了。但我很确定这个夏天，我要把它弄清楚。所有答案都在丛林深处的那些失落城市中。而幸运的凯文，他即将看到每一个城市。
Palenque, Chichén Itzá, Teotihuacan, Uxmal, Mitla, Templo del Sol. I can name these things, but I can't remember them. They all just blend together for me as rocks crumbling. And the idea of seeing the ruins wasn't-- that was your idea why you would be going to Mexico. At 16, just turned 16, I knew there was going to be beer. I knew there was going to be ladies at the tourist spots, and hopefully surf good, warm water.
帕伦克，奇琴伊察，特奥蒂瓦坎，乌斯马尔，米特拉，太阳神庙。我能列举这些东西，但我记不住它们。对我来说，它们只是混合在一起的碎石块。看遗迹的想法不是——那是你想去墨西哥的原因。在 16 岁，刚满 16 岁，我知道会有啤酒。我知道在旅游景点会有女士，希望有好的、温暖的海水冲浪。
I have no recollection of surf being on the itinerary. I mean, I don't know--
我没有任何冲浪在行程上的回忆。我的意思是，我不知道——
So off we went with our high hopes-- such wildly different high hopes-- into Mexico. To get us to the important places where I wanted to be, most days I'd need to drive us for stretches of six or eight hours. A lot of times, Kevin just wanted to stop, like in a village, and see stuff. But there could be no stopping.
所以我们带着我们的高期望出发了——如此狂野地不同的高期望——进入墨西哥。为了让我们到达我想去的重要地方，大多数日子我需要开车六到八个小时。很多时候，凯文只想停下来，比如在村子里，看看东西。但不能有停顿。
When we did pull into little towns, people were curious about the two gringos who showed up in their pueblo. They'd ask questions, and I'd tell them to mind their own business. I wasn't some freak show oddity. What I was was a pretentious douchebag who could not be bothered to interact with the common man.
当我们确实开进小镇时，人们对出现在他们小镇的两个 gringo（外国人）很好奇。他们会问问题，我会告诉他们管好自己的事。我不是什么怪胎表演。我是一个傲慢的混蛋，懒得和普通人互动。
Kevin, though, was, like, energized by being around other people, and the more the merrier. He loved it when we were in the beach towns full of American tourists. And in the small villages, he'd fumble through the few Spanish words that he knew, and he'd start these inane conversations with everybody. It grated on me.
凯文，不过，被周围的人充满活力，越多越好。他喜欢我们在充满美国游客的海滨小镇。在小村庄里，他会笨拙地使用他所知道的几个西班牙语单词，并开始与所有人进行这些愚蠢的对话。这让我很烦。
I wasn't much better on the road. Driving on mountain highways was frigging unnerving, especially at night. And a lot of the time, the map just did not seem to reflect the reality on the ground. My Spanish wasn't great, but the little phrases that I used to navigate around Baja weren't working for me here. The dialects were different. I couldn't understand a lot of the responses. And I didn't handle it well, which I couldn't hide from Kevin, who was sitting right next to me.
我在路上也没好到哪去。在山路公路上开车非常令人不安，特别是在晚上。很多时候，地图似乎并没有反映地面上的真实情况。我的西班牙语不是很好，但我用来在下加利福尼亚州导航的那些小短语在这里对我不起作用。方言不同。我听不懂很多回应。我处理得不好，我无法向坐在我旁边的凯文隐瞒这一点。
As we'd pull away from the people, so often, I remember that you'd be like, (WHISPERING) oh, that fucking idiot. Or god, I just asked a simple question. And just kind of continually watching you, the navigator, ask, [SPEAKING SPANISH]. And I'd just be like, god, he just asked that question two turns ago. I knew he didn't understand what the guy said. So much in my head, I would just be like, pfft, you're calling that guy a fucking idiot, but I can even understand what he said.
当我们离开人们时，我经常记得你会说，（耳语）哦，那个该死的白痴。或者天哪，我只是问了一个简单的问题。只是不断地看着你，那个领航员问，[说西班牙语]。我只会说，天哪，他两转前刚问过那个问题。我知道他没听懂那个人说了什么。我脑子里想得太多，我只会说，噗，你叫那家伙是个该死的白痴，但我甚至听不懂他说什么。
We drove south through Mazatlan and down to Puerto Vallarta. It was all green and jungly and full of tourists having fun. I knew that I was better than them. I wasn't here for the parasailing and the tequila poppers. I had a mission. This is from my journal entry about the ruins at Ixtlán del Rio.
我们开车南下经过马萨特兰，到达巴亚尔塔港。到处都是绿色和丛林，充满了享受乐趣的游客。我知道我比他们强。我来这里不是为了帆伞运动和龙舌兰酒。我有个任务。这是我关于 Ixtlán del Rio 遗迹的日记条目。
"July 22, 3:01 PM-- this temple is the highest of the 15-plus structures found here. The floor of the temple structure is 4 feet off the ground and is reached by six narrow, steep steps. There's a perimeter wall that runs the circumference, save for four entranceways, not equidistant. The wall reaches to 10 feet above the ground and has in its design symmetrical crosses as portholes all the way around, 41 of them. The material of construction at this site is--"
“7 月 22 日，下午 3:01——这座神庙是这里发现的 15 个以上结构中最高的一个。神庙结构的地板离地面 4 英尺，通过六级狭窄、陡峭的台阶到达。有一道围墙绕着周长，除了四个入口，不完全等距。墙壁高出地面 10 英尺，其设计中有对称的十字作为观察孔，绕着一圈，共有 41 个。该地点的建筑材料是……”
The journal is 190 pages long. And late into every night, I wrote down all of the important Mesoamerican anthropology stuff from the trip, which includes virtually no people-- at least no living people. If you were forced to read this entire journal and then tried to deduce the importance of the Kevin character in my life, you might guess that he was maybe Boy in Taco Stand or Boy at Beach Number Four. He just didn't figure into my narrative.
日记有 190 页长。每天深夜，我都把旅行中所有重要的美索不达米亚人类学内容写下来，其中包括几乎没有人的内容——至少没有活人。如果你被迫阅读这整本日记，然后试图推断凯文这个角色在我生命中的重要性，你可能会猜他大概是“塔可摊位的男孩”或“四号海滩的男孩”。他只是没出现在我的叙述中。
And one other thing about this journal-- and I'm not sure how to say this except to just say it. Along the way, I met some girls. And if things went well with those girls, then they would earn a little note at the top of the journal page for the day right above the groundbreaking archaeological data. And the note would say, for example, "remember Blanca." And I totally do remember Blanca. So there's that.
关于这本日记还有一件事——除了直接说出来我不知道怎么说。一路上，我遇到了一些女孩。如果和那些女孩相处得好，那么她们会在那天的日记页顶部，在开创性的考古数据上方赢得一个小小的备注。备注会说，例如，“记住布兰卡”。我确实记得布兰卡。所以就是这样。
For me, it was all ruins, all the time. We drove to the ancient Toltec city of Tula and visited Aztec temples at Tenayuca and Santa Cecilia and the ruins of Teotihuacan. And by "visited," I mean that we spent hours and hours at each site while I mapped and logged every important detail, while Kevin must have been doing something. In general, he was a pretty good sport about it. Clearly, it wasn't his thing. But what was he going to do?
对我来说，全是遗迹，全是时间。我们开车去了古托尔特克城市图拉，参观了特纳尤卡和圣塞西莉亚的阿兹特克神庙以及特奥蒂瓦坎的遗迹。所谓的“参观”，是指我们在每个地点花费数小时，而我绘制并记录了每一个重要的细节，而凯文一定在做别的事情。总的来说，他对此是个相当不错的运动。显然，那不是他的爱好。但他能做什么呢？
How are we doing at this point? How are we getting along, at this point, in your recollection?
到目前为止我们做得怎么样？按照你的回忆，我们相处得如何？
Fine. I think there would be times where we'd talk and be like, let's just not talk, or something. Pretty civilly getting through any frustrations. I wouldn't have gone yet and called you names I don't think.
很好。我想会有时候我们聊着聊着就说，别说话了，或者类似的。相当文明地处理任何挫折。我想我还没开始骂你那些名字。
Not yet. Every night ended the exact same way, with me studying and compulsively writing notes in my journal late into the night with the light on while Kevin tried to sleep. He complained about it constantly, as if turning out the lights was more important than what I was writing. I just kept writing. I felt like the answers that I needed could be parsed later from the details that I wrote, and not like in a New Agey way. I mean like in a real anthropological way. So I kept writing.
还没有。每个晚上结束时都一模一样，我在学习，在深夜强迫性地在日记里记笔记，开着灯，而凯文试着睡觉。他不断地抱怨，好像熄灯比我写的东西更重要。我只是继续写。我觉得我需要的答案以后可以从我写的细节中分析出来，而不是以新时代的方式。我是指以真正的人类学方式。所以我继续写。
And I drew a ton, too-- these really intricate field sketches of Aztec and Mayan designs. And then I mapped out all these ancient cities. There was no reason for this. All of the cities had already been mapped by actual archaeologists. Also, I had a camera. I took hundreds of pictures. Kevin appears in three of them.
我也画了很多——这些非常复杂的阿兹特克和玛雅设计的实地素描。然后我绘制了所有这些古城的地图。这没有理由。所有的城市都已经由真正的考古学家绘制过了。此外，我还有个相机。我拍了几百张照片。凯文出现在其中三张里。
At this point, if you were going to write a letter to your best friend, or a postcard to your best friend about your brother, what would it have said?
现在，如果你要给最好的朋友写封信，或者给最好的朋友写张关于你哥哥的明信片，会写什么？
The postcard, I'm sure, would say, having fun traveling through Mexico, but my brother's pretty much an [BLEEP]-hole. I probably would've said, I'm getting kind of sick of him, but I'm sure we can get through this. The next fun place ahead.
明信片，我确定会说，在墨西哥旅行很有趣，但我哥哥基本上是个混蛋。我可能还会说，我有点厌倦他了，但我确信我们能度过难关。前方下一个有趣的地方。
One day, Kevin met a girl about his age. She was Mexican. All I remember about her is that she spoke some English, and she had a small head. Kevin introduced me, and I was probably just my normal self. She told Kevin, your brother is really sangron, which I learned later that night means arrogant.
一天，凯文遇到了一个和他年纪相当的女孩。她是墨西哥人。我唯一记得关于她的是她会说一点英语，而且她有个小脑袋。凯文向我介绍，我可能只是我正常的自己。她告诉凯文，你哥哥真是 sangron（傲慢），我那天晚上后来才知道这意味着傲慢。
Kevin reveled in a great many retellings of that. He loved letting me know that everybody thought I was a prick. And for some reason, this particular jab from the small-headed girl really hit me hard because I normally had to work a little to make people dislike me. But I hadn't done that with her. She could tell that I was an arrogant jerk in my normal resting state.
凯文陶醉于那句评价的多次重述中。他喜欢让我知道每个人都认为我是个混蛋。出于某种原因，来自那个小脑袋女孩的这个特殊的刺真的击中了我的要害，因为我通常需要一点工作来让人们不喜欢我。但我没对她做那样的事。她能看出我处于正常休息状态时是个傲慢的混蛋。
Sangron became Kevin's new favorite word when we argued, and it drove me crazy. But even when Kevin was happy, he was driving me crazy now-- his whole "cheerful, surfer, stoked-to-be-around-people" thing.
当我们争吵时，Sangron 成为了凯文最喜欢的新词，这让我抓狂。但即使凯文快乐时，他现在也让我抓狂——他整个“快乐、冲浪者、对身边人感到兴奋”的样子。
It's funny, though, because I remember, as a little kid, I was the same way. In second grade, the teacher wrote a comment in my report card that said I was a bubbly student. That night, when our stepfather got home from the machine shop and read it, I got beat. He said he knew what the teacher meant-- that I was a loudmouth. I changed.
这很有趣，因为我记得，小时候，我也一样。二年级时，老师在我的成绩单上写了一条评论，说我是个活泼的学生。那天晚上，当我们的继父从机器厂下班回来读到它时，我被打了。他说他知道老师是什么意思——我是个大嘴巴。我变了。
We spent a few days in Mexico City and worked our way south to Oaxaca on little two-lane roads and muddy trails. Kevin suggested that maybe we should skip some of the more remote ruins and head straight for the beach. And I told him no [BLEEP] way. We crossed the isthmus and over to the ruins in Campeche in Yucatan. And just when it seemed that Kevin was ready to mutiny, we were saved by our next stop on the map-- Cancun.
我们在墨西哥城待了几天，然后沿着两条车道的小路和泥泞的小径向南往瓦哈卡走。凯文建议也许我们应该跳过一些更偏远的遗迹，直接去海滩。我告诉他去他妈的。我们穿过地峡，去了坎佩切和尤卡坦的遗迹。就在凯文准备兵变时，我们被地图上的下一站——坎昆——救了。
Drinking and night life and beautiful beaches and scuba and snorkeling and beautiful water.
喝酒、夜生活、美丽的海滩、潜水和浮潜，还有美丽的水。
Cancun was amazing in those days-- just this Caribbean paradise and lots of ruins. But it was OK. I was certain we could see and do it all. In fact, the days in Cancun might have been the best of the entire trip. We were both excited to get out to the islands.
那时的坎昆令人惊叹——只是这个加勒比天堂，还有许多遗迹。但这没关系。我确定我们可以看完并做完这一切。事实上，在坎昆的日子可能是整个旅行中最好的。我们俩都很兴奋去岛上。
There was that island just offshore called Isla Mujeres, which sounded great to me because I knew mujeres meant women. So we got on some sort of just-- we didn't bring the car. We just went out there ourselves. No car. A ferry out there, I think.
离岸有一个叫女人岛的岛，听起来对我很好，因为我知道 mujeres 意味着女人。所以我们——我们没带车。我们只是自己去那儿。没有车。我想是坐渡轮过去。
And then we got there pretty late, I want to say. Long day-- and we found kind of a real quiet bar and started drinking, putting down some drinks. And then it was time to go up to our hotel, which is a fairly meager hotel, nothing fancy, and start turning in for the night.
然后我们到那儿挺晚的。漫长的一天——我们找到了一个相当安静的酒吧开始喝酒，喝了几杯。然后是时候去我们的酒店了，一个相当简陋的酒店，没什么特别的，开始休息一晚。
And you, making notations in your journal, and it got to an argument in that hotel that night, where I pretty much let my mouth fly. And I said all the things I felt, which included, you think you're so cool. You think you're so much better than everyone around here. And I'm sure included in that was, you're a fucking idiot. You're a fucking idiot. You're fucking not as cool as you think you are.
而你，在日记里做笔记，那天晚上在酒店里引发了争论，在那里我几乎让我的嘴飞了起来。我说出了我所有的感受，包括，你以为你很酷。你以为你比这里的所有人都强。我确信这还包括，你是个该死的白痴。你是个该死的白痴。你并没有你想象的那么酷。
And I went to the pimples on your face. I went to the chicks you had chosen. I went to how you treat everybody like shit. And you still didn't get up out of that bed or stop writing in your book. And it was a "volcano erupting out of my mouth" time. I would not stop. I would not stop. And I got you grinding your teeth and standing up.
我还攻击了你脸上的痘痘。我攻击了你挑选的女孩。我攻击了你对待每个人像屎一样的方式。而你仍然没有从那张床上站起来或停止在书里写字。那是“火山从我嘴里喷发”的时刻。我不会停止。我不会停止。而且我让你咬牙切齿，站了起来。
And you said, I'm going to fucking hit you if you say another word. I think it was that. And I, of course, just said probably one of the slowest (SLOWLY) fuck yous. And that's pretty much when I got a slug right to the lip, I'd say. Good fat lip. fly backwards, oh! Towel rack fell when I flew back.
你说，如果你再说一个字，我就要打爆你了。我想是这样。当然，我只是说了大概最慢的一个（缓慢地）去你的。这差不多就是我被重击在嘴唇上的时候。好一个大肿嘴。向后飞，哦！向后飞的时候毛巾架倒了。
And I stood up tall, but I didn't hit back. I just let that mouth go some more. That didn't hurt. Do it again. Do it again. Fuck you. Fucking doesn't hurt. Doesn't hurt.
我站得笔直，但我没打回去。我只是让那张嘴又说了一些。那不疼。再来一次。再来一次。去你的。该死的根本不疼。不疼。
Every horrid thing that he said in that room-- I knew he was right. I agreed with him, so I punished him bad. Threw him into a nightstand, shattered a lamp, upended a bed. There was blood. The door was blocked with the mattress, so we escaped out the window, ran down to the courtyard outside the hotel. Next door was a jungle gym. And the way I remember it--
他在那个房间里说的每一句恐怖的话——我知道他是对的。我同意他的看法，所以我惩罚了他。把他扔进床头柜，摔碎了一个台灯，翻倒了一张床。有血迹。门被床垫堵住了，所以我们从窗户逃走了，跑到酒店外面的庭院。隔壁是一个丛林健身房。按我的记忆——
My recollection-- you were yelling for me to get away from you. You were running around the jungle gym on the opposite side because you thought I was coming back for you more. And I was trying to say, no, no, no. You don't understand. I should not have done that. I'm sorry.
我的回忆——你在喊让我离你远点。你在丛林健身房的另一边跑来跑去，因为你以为我要回来再打你。我试着说，不，不，不。你不明白。我不应该那样做。我很抱歉。
Over and over, I apologized to Kevin, swore it would never happen again, but it was too late. Kevin was done.
我一遍又一遍地向凯文道歉，发誓再也不会那样做了，但已经太晚了。凯文受够了。
I was 100% down to leave because I did have the control at that moment. That was the one thing I could control. I could control saying I want to leave. I just didn't want to be with-- on that trip anymore. I just didn't want to be with you anymore. It wasn't the environment we were in. It was you.
我 100% 准备好离开，因为那一刻我有控制权。那是我能控制的一件事。我可以控制说我想离开。我只是不想在那次旅行中待下去了。我只是不想再和你待在一起了。这不是我们所处的环境。是你。
I had told you when we got in a fight-- and I know you remember this-- I said, it's never going to be the same between us. That's it. It's over. I'm never going to respect you. It's never going to be the same again. You call me up, I won't even-- probably at that time, I would say I wouldn't talk to you.
我们在吵架时我告诉过你——我知道你记得这个——我说，我们之间永远不会一样了。就是这样。结束了。我永远不会尊重你。它永远不会再一样了。你给我打电话，我甚至不会——可能在那时，我会说我不会和你说话。
But by the next day-- I remember your face and I knew your emotions well-- you were sorry, and you were sad that things weren't going to be the same. You knew it. You said, I know they won't.
但到第二天——我记得你的脸，我知道你的情绪——你很抱歉，你很伤心事情不会再一样了。你知道的。你说，我知道不会了。
The next morning, we got back on the ferry and then drove without a word to the Cancun airport, where we bought Kevin a one-way ticket to San Diego.
第二天早上，我们坐渡轮回来，然后一言不发地开车去坎昆机场，在那里我们给凯文买了一张去圣地亚哥的单程票。
I continued on alone to Belize and Guatemala and then turned back up to Mexico, where I stayed for the next four years. My mailing address was Lista de Correios, just General Delivery. And I didn't have a phone. It wasn't on purpose. Almost nobody in the town had phones. But also, I didn't want a phone. I cut myself off almost entirely from my family, not just during the years in Mexico, but even after I returned.
我独自继续前往伯利兹和危地马拉，然后转回墨西哥，我在那里待了接下来的四年。我的邮寄地址是 Lista de Correios，也就是通用投递。我没有电话。这不是故意的。镇上几乎没有人有电话。但此外，我也不想要电话。我几乎完全切断了与家人的联系，不仅是在墨西哥的几年里，甚至在我回来后也是如此。
Kevin had been the very last person left standing in my corner, and I think this trip, at least in hindsight, had been like a bridge to fix things back home and show that I wasn't such a bad guy. Instead, it only proved what I'd always feared-- I was a bad guy.
凯文是我角落里留下的最后一个人，我想这次旅行，至少在回顾时，就像一座修补家里事情的桥梁，证明我不是个那么坏的家伙。相反，它只证明了我一直害怕的事情——我是个坏家伙。
What I didn't know through all this time was that Kevin actually did get over this stuff-- quickly. Pretty much as soon as he got back to San Diego. He had said things would never be the same, but "never" means something different to a 16-year-old kid. And I guess I'm not surprised Kevin's over it. He's not, like, one of those pricks who holds a grudge.
通过所有这些时间我不知道的是，凯文实际上确实克服了这些事情——很快。基本上他一回到圣地亚哥就克服了。他说事情永远不会一样，但“永远”对一个 16 岁的孩子来说意味着不同的东西。我想凯文克服了它我并不惊讶。他不是那种记仇的混蛋。
I'm the one who couldn't let it go, any of it. That trip in Mexico, for me to hit him, to beat him the way that I did after the childhood we had-- I felt ashamed. Kevin and I had never really sat down and talked about this, but I know I let him down-- not just in Mexico-- long before that, all through our childhood. There were beatings, just this violence, like, every other day.
是我无法放手，任何事情。那次墨西哥之行，我打他，在我们经历了童年后我那样打他——我感到羞耻。凯文和我从来没有真正坐下来谈论这个，但我知道我让他失望了——不仅仅是在墨西哥——在那之前很久，在我们的整个童年里。有殴打，就像每隔一天一次的暴力。
When I was nine, I saw my stepfather throw Kevin face-first into the sharp corner of a wall. It opened up his forehead-- so much blood. Kevin was four years old. Even now, almost 40 years later, sitting in front of him, I can barely stand to tell him what happened when we took him to the emergency room.
当我九岁时，我看到继父把凯文的脸朝前扔进墙的尖角。它划开了他的额头——那么多血。凯文当时四岁。即使现在，近 40 年后，坐在他面前，我几乎无法忍受告诉他我们带他去急诊室时发生了什么。
Right off the bat, stepfather saying, ah, he tripped and fell. He's bleeding. Need to get that fixed. And they asked Mom, and she gave the company line. And then they asked me, and I said, yeah. He tripped and fell.
刚开始，继父说，啊，他绊倒摔倒了。他在流血。需要去处理一下。他们问妈妈，她给出了公司的口径。然后他们问我，我说，是的。他绊倒摔倒了。
Mm-hmm.
嗯哼。
And as the older brother, I had a responsibility. I mean, regardless of what was beaten out of me, I had this responsibility. I mean, and it hits me now while I look at your face. You've got that-- I mean, that scar is a part of you that is a part that I wish I could forget.
作为哥哥，我有责任。我的意思是，不管我被揍出了什么，我有这个责任。我的意思是，当我看你的脸时，现在它击中了我。你有那个——我的意思是，那个伤疤是你的一部分，我希望我能忘记的一部分。
I bet.
我敢打赌。
And we would go visit Dad every other weekend. And he would ask, and I wouldn't say anything, you know? I just-- I wouldn't do it. And then--
我们会每隔一个周末去拜访爸爸。他会问，我什么都不会说，你知道吗？我只是——我不会那么做的。然后——
Our dad didn't know what our stepfather was doing to us until one weekend when Kevin was nine. Kevin had been beaten badly, and he must've said something to Dad.
我们的爸爸不知道我们的继父在对我们做什么，直到一个周末凯文九岁的时候。凯文被打得很惨，他一定对爸爸说了什么。
I don't know. I don't even-- I wasn't there. I don't even know what you said.
我不知道。我甚至——我不在那儿。我甚至不知道你说了什么。
Well, you were there. You were there. We were going to Dad and Kathy's on Cove Drive. And Kathy wasn't there. He took a little bit different way. We were on a more scenic route from Lakeside, like the 67. Remember the sunset and the mountain road.
嗯，你在那儿。你在那儿。我们要去爸爸和凯西在 Cove Drive 的家。凯西不在那儿。他走了一条稍微不同的路。我们走的是从湖滨出来的风景更好的路，比如 67 号。记得日落和山路吗。
And I remember I had just told him that, oh yeah, I got beat for leaving the paint out. And then, after getting beat and told to come back out in the living room, I spent about 40 seconds feeling sorry and trying to act normal-- that 40 seconds passed, and I didn't pick up the paint again, and so I got beat again for not picking up the paint. And it just was--
我还记得我刚告诉他，哦，是的，我因为把油漆落在外面被揍了。然后，在被揍并被叫回客厅后，我花了大约 40 秒感到抱歉并试着表现得正常——那 40 秒过去了，我没再去捡油漆，所以我因为没捡油漆又被揍了一次。这简直就是——
Was this the electrical cord?
这是电线吗？
Um, that time it was. Back of the knees to the middle of the back.
嗯，那次是。从膝盖后部到背部中部。
The only thing that it took to get us out of that bad situation was for somebody to speak up, for me to tell my dad-- my real dad-- the truth about our life at home. But I was too afraid to say anything, so I said nothing. And this fact, more than most any other, makes me hate myself because I was the big brother. It was my responsibility to speak up, to protect Kevin. Instead, he's the one who stood up. He's the one who told our dad.
让我们摆脱那种糟糕处境的唯一条件就是有人说出来，我对我爸爸——我真正的爸爸——说出我们家里生活的真相。但我太害怕说出任何话了，所以我什么也没说。这个事实，比大多数其他任何事情都让我恨自己，因为我是大哥。我有责任说出来，保护凯文。相反，他是站出来的那个人。他是告诉我们爸爸的那个人。
And he called CPS. He called the police. They took Polaroids, in the room, of my bare ass and back. And we sat around a table and the policeman asked us, I want you to name every time you've been beat. That was the table there on Cove Drive, the dinner table. And we looked at each other like, oh, do you have a while?
他打了 CPS（儿童保护服务）。他报了警。他们在房间里拍了我的光屁股和后背的宝丽来照片。我们围着桌子坐着，警察问我们，我想要你们列出你们每一次被揍的情况。那就是 Cove Drive 的那张桌子，餐桌。我们面面相觑，像是，哦，你有时间吗？
And for years after that conversation, for years, maybe decades, I thought of what I had forgot to tell that guy. Oh, I never mentioned that time. And I'd know right away that I hadn't mentioned that. It would pop into my head and go, oh. I didn't mention that.
在那次谈话后的几年里，几年，也许几十年，我想到了我忘了告诉那个家伙的事情。哦，我从来没提过那一次。我会马上知道我没提过那个。它会跳进我的脑海里，去，哦。我没提过那个。
Telling Kevin that I was sorry about the fight in Mexico-- that was one thing. Talking about the stuff that happened when we were little-- what I didn't do, apologizing for not protecting him as a kid-- that's what I really needed to say to him.
告诉凯文我很抱歉在墨西哥的那场架——那是一回事。谈论我们小时候发生的那些事情——我没做什么，为小时候没保护他道歉——那才是我真正需要对他说的。
For the past 20 years, I've lived like half an hour from Kevin. He invites me to stuff all the time, but I don't go. And I'm not much of an inviter. I don't see him much or the rest of the family, either. Our past has always held me back. I've got a lot of regret.
过去 20 年里，我住在离凯文半小时路程的地方。他总是邀请我参加各种活动，但我没去。我也不太擅长邀请别人。我没怎么见到他和家里的其他人。我们的过去一直阻碍着我。我有很多遗憾。
I'm kind of sad to hear that you have so much remorse over it. I don't blame you for it, and I don't blame you for being older and should have known better. That is something that happened a long time ago. And I don't want you to be tortured by your past. And I hope I haven't done anything to continue the torture. You're loved.
听到你对这件事有这么多懊悔我感到有点难过。我不怪你，我也不怪你那时年纪大应该懂得更多。那是很久以前发生的事情。我不希望你被你的过去所折磨。我希望我没有做任何事来继续这种折磨。你被爱着。
I'm a different person now than I was at 21-- mostly. It took a long time to get my karma straight. But I'm still not a guy who's going to start a conversation with you on an elevator. And I'd rather you didn't, either. Also, I waited a long time, but I'm married now. I have a daughter who's nine and a son who's seven. They have a very different life than the one Kevin and I had.
我现在是个不同于 21 岁时的人了——大部分情况。花了好长时间才让我的因果得到改善。但我仍然不是那种会在电梯里和你开启对话的家伙。我也不希望你那样做。另外，我等了很长时间，但我现在结婚了。我有一个九岁的女儿和一个七岁的儿子。他们有着与凯文和我完全不同的生活。
I'm going to have this one.
我要选这个。
A couple of weeks after we spoke, Kevin asked us to come to Thanksgiving at his house. I drove up with my wife and my kids and a vegetable dish. There were a lot of people-- like 22. Extended family-- people who see each other regularly but don't see me much at all. Kevin likes having all this family around. It makes me a little anxious.
我们谈话几周后，凯文邀请我们去他家参加感恩节。我和我的妻子、孩子带着一道蔬菜菜肴开车过去。人很多——大概 22 个。大家庭——人们经常见面但不怎么见我。凯文喜欢家里有这么多人。这让我有点焦虑。
My kids played with his kids. Nobody got punched in the face. It was nice. I think I hoped to see them at Christmas.
我的孩子们和他的孩子们玩耍。没人被揍。很好。我想我希望圣诞节见到他们。
James Spring in San Diego. In the four years since we first broadcast this story, he and his brother and their families have spent Christmases together-- other times, too.
詹姆斯·斯普林在圣地亚哥。自我们首次播出这个故事的四年里，他和他的哥哥以及他们的家人一起度过了圣诞节——其他时候也一样。
[MUSIC - RUFUS WAINWRIGHT, "HE AIN'T HEAVY, HE'S MY BROTHER"]
[音乐 - 鲁弗斯·温莱特，《他并不沉重，他是我兄弟》]
Our program was produced today by Miki Meek. Our senior producer for this episode was Julie Snyder. Our technical director is Matt Tierney. Production help from Alvin Melathe.
我们今天的节目由米基·米克制作。我们这一集的资深制片人是朱莉·斯奈德。我们的技术总监是马特·蒂尔尼。由阿尔文·梅拉思协助制作。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
[致谢]
Our website-- thisamericanlife.org. This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange.
我们的网站——thisamericanlife.org。《美国生活》由公共广播交换中心 PRX 发送到公共广播电台。
Thanks, as always, to our program's cofounder, Mr. Torey Malatia. You know, he told me the first time he went to a board meeting-- like, a real board meeting, at WBEZ-- he was totally disappointed. He thought there was going to be milk and cookies and all the candy you could eat.
一如既往地感谢我们节目的联合创始人托里·马拉蒂亚先生。你知道，他告诉我他第一次去参加董事会会议的时候——比如，一个真正的董事会会议，在 WBEZ——他彻底失望了。他以为会有牛奶和饼干，还有所有你能吃的糖果。
It was very businesslike. It wasn't what they show in the movies at all.
那非常公事公办。这根本不是电影里演的那样。
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周带着更多《美国生活》的故事回来。
[MUSIC - RUFUS WAINWRIGHT, "HE AIN'T HEAVY, HE'S MY BROTHER"]
[音乐 - 鲁弗斯·温莱特，《他并不沉重，他是我兄弟》]